okay so it starts off with you and your
roof being picked up by Bill Burr in a
helicopter not a small shitty helicopter
a big military grade [__] helicopter
with a ladder dangling off it was there
a harness was there I I did for for when
I was flying around I was flying around
all goddamn day and there was a safety
line that came up through my shirt which
connected me to the ladder but that that
wasn't going to help me when it was time
for me to drop from the rope ladder on
and also connecting to it and fly off
your roof you you can see that's a still
I just grabbed it and it picked me up
and flew me off [__] man cuz Bill
Bill's not a stunt hel I know he's got a
his license there's also a bit where
Bill's just dunking him into the water I
got to let go of the rope ladder while
I'm dangling from the helicopter and
land on the roof of my moving tour bus
Bill flies over the top he's on a
helicopter steveo lands on the [__]
bus climbs down the side of the bus
where he's met by his beautiful
girlfriend lovely